who in the audience is new to pandas
awesome cool and who in the audience
uses our oh cool all right so I guess
this is gonna work out for everyone
since it's I sort of wrote this talk
sort of as a as an intro for both sides
so um I guess I will be sitting since i
since this was this presentation that's
no longer in presentation so everything
is online um because that's how it's on
this computer right now so this is my
twitter handle and also my github user
name so you can also find all of this
stuff there the datasets that i'm using
are also in the repository so you can
hopefully this works that like
everything is self-contained so I'm
Daniel I'm a graduate student at
Virginia Tech and the genetics
bioinformatics and computational biology
program my lab is up here in ballston in
the social decision analytics lab even
though my school is about five hours
away from here and I'm part of the bio
complexity Institute Virginia Tech and
for certain things more numb focus pi
data related I am also one of the co
maintained errs for the programming with
our lesson um through software carpentry
so uh I sort of asked the question
alright already already but to reiterate
or to extend on it who uses both Python
and our or oh nice and then who hates
the people who uses the other language
anyone know alright so Jake van der plas
actually sent a tweet earlier last month
or within the past month and you pretty
much just said that yes there's really
no need for this fighting between
language it is no one language it's
better than the other I bounced around
the two languages and depending on what
I need I'll just do it in whatever
language I feel comfortable in and so
just a little overview the datasets I'm
going to be going through so there is an
Ebola dataset that was catered by
someone knows in my
program two years ago um she curated an
Ebola dataset so this is coming from the
World Health Organization and a bunch of
repositories and she sort of created a
central data repository during the 2014
evil outbreak so that's some of the day
we'll be looking at there's a survey
data set that comes from the SQL
software carpentry library and then
we'll also use a cleaned-up data set
that Jack Jenny Brian uses at the very
end also so Python some of you guys said
that you're new to python and just two
or new two pandas but who is actually
new to like python light in general all
right all right cool so if you start
learning python and then you start
realizing hey we can do data analytics
and python you're going to end up with
like another wall where data analytics
and python is also it's a little
different than regular python there are
certain idioms that if you're just going
from the program inside totally doesn't
exist in regular and if you're going
from the programming side it doesn't
happen or those idioms don't really work
in the data analytics side and if you
there is a link to a talk that James
Powell which is also part who is also
part of x data and um focus on the
differences on vernacular between the
analytic side and the Python side so if
you're really new to python how do you
get it we use anaconda it's sort of the
one place to get everything you need at
least in this pi data stack except for
this one library that i'll show you in a
little bit i've had a little problem
with it but but how do you run it so
there's three ways orders I've list six
ways you can run this you can type
Python in a terminal and get a blinking
cursor version of Python you can type
ipython in a criminal and you'll get a
more fancy blinking cursor version of
Python it's got a few it's got a few
nice features with ipython especially if
you want to time your code timing is
sort of built-in let me make that a
little bit
since people are swimming yeah and then
there's for those of you who are used to
like I des hommes if you install
anaconda spider comes with anaconda
rodeo which is built by Y hat there's a
booth downstairs if you want to talk to
them they also have an IDE and then
there's another one that's pretty
popular I personally don't use it but
you can use pycharm as well so how do
you use Python or how do you use the
analytic stack the first thing you do is
so this is what you're looking at now
the Jupiter notebook so this is if I go
into a terminal and I type in Jupiter
notebook this pops up and to use pandas
you type import pandas SPD so you import
the data analytics essentially pandas
which is a data analytics library you
import this in and instead of saying
pandas calling each functions by saying
pandas dot read CSV for example um
because you'll be using this library
over and over again all the functions
inside you can short you can give it
like a temporary nickname called PD so
you'll see your code instead of pandas
dot read CSV over and over again you'll
be pd read CSV and all the other
functions that you need and so we'll
load up our first data set its will use
the read CSV function it comes from
pandas so it's pd3 CSV and we'll look at
the bola de set so this is pretty much a
view that you would get just as if you
open it up in Excel or in spreadsheets
of rectangular view and you can call the
function head just to get the first five
five row so you don't need to like look
at a million rows you just get the first
five rows if you are in the regular
Python mode so when you just type in
pure python if you want to get the
output of something back you have to
wrap it around a print function so print
Ebola DF head will print out the same
view you just won't get it it just won't
look as pretty because of the
interactive nature sort of pretty makes
it pretty for you so
alright so the first thing you do when
you load up a data set you want to see
what's in here so there are two pretty
good convenience functions that pandas
has info what it will do is they'll
pretty much give you a bunch of
information about the data if you loaded
the column names how many non missing
values there are and the type of column
in there so for example you can see that
we have a date column it's got 122
values because there's a hundred and
twenty two entries we actually there
aren't any missing date values in this
column and then its object it's an has
an object type which means that it's
just a generic type so it's really
casted like a string and you can see
that there's other types like integers
or floating point numbers etc etc and
you can see a list of all of the columns
in this data set another way when you
first load up a data set is to use the
describe function so what this will do
is give you some pretty basic statistics
on what's going on in each column so it
is a pretty good way of just doing you
know one off things for everything right
like some of these might not make sense
especially if you have categorical
variables but you know this will give
you a good count on mean and standard
deviation of all your data alright so
subsetting there's a few ways you can
subset in Python so what you can do is
have a data frame use a square bracket
within the square bracket put in quotes
the column that you want and you'll get
all of the data for that call if it's
really just one column that you're
working with you'll see a lot a lot of
code especially on the Internet instead
of using a square bracket and then
quotes they'll just say data frame dot
and then the column directly so you
you'll see both um it's really like a
convenience way so you don't use kind of
save about four characters of typing but
you'll see that around if you need to
subset multiple columns you now have to
give the sub setting I guess it's not
really a function but you have to give
the sub setter a container of all of the
columns that you want so that's why you
see 22 double brackets
and then in here in the innermost double
bracket I'll list all of the columns I
want so here I'm just looking for today
and the cases in Guinea and I'll get to
commons back instead of one now if you
want to subset rose actually I'm still
doing columns so if you want a subset
columns instead of specifying by column
name you can also specify by the actual
column number or the index the position
that it's in python is zero index so the
first column is really index zero so if
I want the first to it i'm looking for a
zero on one if you're going for real
wise instead of using the plane square
brackets there's three functions that
you're going to have to that you'll see
depending on where you where you're
looking let me close all of this there
we go so the first one is dot LOC
followed by square bracket and in here
you get to specify the road that you
want by the row name so all of our row
names we didn't give them any special
names really so the row name is really
the same thing as the row index in this
example but when you're working with
time series data is actually pretty
common to have like the date as d rho
name for example the next one is i loke
so you can use also same way but you get
to specified by the row number instead
of dro name and then you'll also see
another way called IX which is which
will look by the name and then a number
so I X is really a more general way of
slicing your data but I'm sort of
showing all three just for I guess for
didactic purposes IX and all of the
other sub setters I showed you on
there's a general there's a general
syntax where you have the outermost
bracket and then within the outermost
bracket there's a comma that separates
two parts the part to the left or the
first part that's how you would sep set
your rows and apart to the right that's
how you would subset your columns so if
you're coming from our or Python there
but actually done exactly the same way
and if you need to subset multiple rows
or columns you given another contain
and then you can subset that way if you
also want you can for example take a
column of your data frame out so in this
case I'm looking at cases from Sierra
Leone and I'm saying I just want all the
cases where all the rows were the number
of cases is greater than 5,000 because
i'm using the IX subset er the left is
how i'm setting the rose and the right
here is how I'm subsetting the columns
and what I get back are the date and
cases Sierra Leone columns for all of
the case for all of the entries that
have more than 5,000 cases right and in
Python if you if you ever start you know
pandas is a pretty fundamental package
so when you start using other libraries
that are built on top of something
that's a data frame some euro you'll end
up getting errors like hey I'm expecting
like an NDA ray and I didn't get an ndr
a you're like well well I gave you a
column isn't that what you wanted so if
you ever get really confused of what's
going on there's a function called type
that you can use in Python and that will
spit out exactly what that the type of
that object is you can see here this is
the same thing as the first one so I got
a series object out in pandas a series
is really a column and a bunch of
columns or a bunch of series put
together is what makes a data frame if
you're working with some of like a bunch
of machine learning libraries or some
other like automation optimization
libraries they actually expect like an
ndr ray and the way to get a series an
NDA way out of a series is using the dot
values property alright so creating new
columns each data frame has an attribute
called shape so we can call shape on
something and will give us a tuple or a
container on the first number 0 tell us
how many rows the second number will
tell us how many columns and if we want
to for example make a calculation we can
say hey take the number of deaths from
Guinea and add it to the column that
represents number of
from Liberia and we can directly assign
it to another column all right so if you
need to make simple calculations with
your columns you can do so pretty direct
and if you look at the shape again
you'll see that the number of columns
went from 18 to 19 missing values so
missing values are something that's
missing an unknown and for a lot of
people who are new to data analytics
they want how do you check for missing
you would expect a missing value is also
equal to another missing value which in
for all of for any analytics library
that you work with na or any missing
values never going to equal another
missing value on the way I think of it
is this value is missing it can really
be anything so you can't really it can
all it could be like the number 42 or 24
and you can't really say that those two
values are going to be the same so
that's why missing values will always
equate the false if you try to get some
kind of truth value out of it in Python
the missing values actually come from
another package called numpy and so it
doesn't really matter how you how you
spell na n all three are exactly the
same and if you actually need to check
for missing value like if it's actually
missing or has a man or not a number of
pandas has a function called is null and
if you pass it that it will give you
whether it is missing or not another way
that you can also count for missing
values is there you can take data frame
you can get the column out of a data
frame and use a function called value
counts and instead of counting all the
non vincent all the non missing values
you can also say hey keep all the
missing values and also cali those as
well and you'll get a count of missing
values if that's what you need to do for
your work all right am i doing tell them
right combining data
so after you load in a bunch of data
sets typically either your data you know
sharted across multiple files or you
need to combine multiple data sets to
create something that you can use to
answer your question so I have two data
frames um they look exactly the same and
depending on where you get your data
from you might want to concatenate your
data row wise it could be you know this
this data set is really four million
rows and so they just broke it up into
four files of a million rows each and
you need to assemble it back so you can
actually do your work so pandas has a
function called can cat and in can cat
you can give it a list of all the data
frames that you want stacked row wise
and I'll just stack them robots for you
likewise if you want you can stack them
column wise as well so you can all you
do is the same function and you provide
the access as one and we'll just stack
it column wise yep
oh yeah so what so the index if he so
she was talking about the index and
you'll know what the index is because
it's the only column that doesn't have a
column name associated with it you
should always have something there and
when you start concatenated Rowland
why's the computer will try to actually
match the index before it concatenates
yeah so if I if or c2 I had a bc e for
example it will create a new column
called e and then all the bees will be
blank so if that's aI don't know we can
also talk offline yeah we can also talk
offline um but yeah yeah yeah it's it's
just a blind stacking of your columns um
there's a I think there's a parameter in
here that will reset index so if you
actually needed to go sequentially on
like the numbers need to go sequentially
you can say hey like ignore the index
and it will just stack it from zero to I
guess I don't know 10 or four or eight
here in this example yes if you if you
use the i loke subset er you can put in
seven and don't get the last one but if
you use loc it'll look for the name and
seven doesn't exist yes yeah so if you
use if you use if you try even if you
try to subset a column of a will give
you both days if you stack it that way
so another way so this is just a blind
concatenating your data pandas also has
ways of merging data sets so for example
in the sir
of a data that I have I have two
examples there is a survey visited data
set and a site data set and if we need
it to combine these two into a single
data frame what we say is the we have
two data frames there's one on the left
and one on the right the one on the left
is the first data frame that you are
mentioning that data frame has a
function called merge and you're merging
it to another data frame on a right and
then how you specify what gets merged
and how you can call there's a parameter
called how so this is outer which means
both sides will be kept you can also
have something called inner merge inner
joins left joins right joins and that
just depends on you know do I only keep
the values that are contained in both or
the left side or the right side if your
column names have different the column
that you want to merge on have different
names you can specify a left on and a
right on and if you pass in a container
you can actually merge on multiple
columns if you need to as well right
vector in group graphics grouped
operations so for this example I'm load
in a gap minor data set and let me try
this let's say for example the example
earlier when I created a new column was
actually pretty simple it was directly
based off of two existing columns doing
a operation on it um doing like a I
think I just what did I do I just added
two columns together but let's say for
example you have a column that you
actually need to do you know string
parsing something that you can't just
add use basic math operations on what
you're going to have to do is sort of
write a function that does all of the
manipulations that you want and then you
can pass that function row wise or
column wise so let me break down this
this a little bit so I'm going to create
a new column called life expectancy life
expectancy per capital it's going to
take the original data frame and now
there's a function called apply if
you're coming from the art world this is
pretty much your your life
but apply what apply does there is
really like two main parameters that you
need the first parameter is a function
that you're going to use and then the
second parameter in this case axis says
the what does this function that you
passive operate on every column or every
row and right now access is one so it's
working on every row but if you leave it
at default the default 0 it'll work on
every column and I have to specify two
different ways what I'm really doing is
for each row I'm getting the life
expectancy value and dividing it by the
population value you can see I specify
this example like two different ways
it's just to show you really they're
both really the same thing but i also am
using also found this out that pop is
actually a python like function for
containers so you can't really say X dot
pop it's not really what that's asking
for so I wanted the pop column not the
function pop that takes the last element
out of the container so if you're not
used to lambda expressions which when I
was first starting out Python and this
whole data analytics tack you can also
do the same thing I wrote up here in a
simpler in like a more traditional
programming way which is define a
function that you want and so I'm
defining a function and this function
takes a row of data alright so that's
the one assumption I know this is going
to be using an applied function so i can
assume that it an entire row is going to
get passed in here and then i'm doing
the same exact calculation I'm saying
this row of data give me the life
expectancy / the population save it to a
value and then return that value and
then the apply function here looks
exactly the same as before its apply but
instead of this weird lambda expression
that I just showed I just passed in that
function directly and then the axis is
still the same and just to prove to you
guys that you know both of the
calculations work exactly the same is
each value of the two columns I created
all the same and it's yes
so they really do work exactly the same
way and so what's really nice about you
know any really data analytics software
what really gives you insight into your
data are grouped operations right so
here in our get minor data let's say we
wanted the average life expectancy and
UDP per capital by each year so we can
take our data frame there is a function
called group by we can group by the year
column so now all of the years are
grouped together from there we're
selecting the life expectancy and GDP
per capital columns from the grouped
data frame and we're calculating to me
and now this gives us a new data frame
where for each year we have all of the
life expectancy and average gdp per
capital if you want you can put another
container here and group I year and
continent or something if that's what
you want yes this mean part is you know
you can really put any real real
calculation that you need uh yes but I
actually don't know that off the top of
my head because I'm standing in front of
you guys yeah yeah um if it's max if
it's group then you don't want like the
max of everyone you only want the max of
a particular year so you don't want yeah
but yeah you can totally use different
operations as well and then no no import
error this is not good oh and last the
last example just or this obviously
didn't work on my computer if you want
to fit a linear model for example
instead of pandas you load up a library
called scikit-learn there is a function
called linear model there and the way
you create a linear model is you
python is an object-oriented language so
you have to first create this object
that's going to be a linear model so you
create the linear model object and then
you pass in you called the fit of method
from this object and you give it all the
data that you want fitted so you have
the all the X's and all the Y's from
your data it will fit it and then once
it's fit you can get the coefficients by
running co f underscore and i'll return
all the coefficients that you need right
and so this was a slideshow and if you
wanted to actually run a slideshow in
the notebook there is a package that Tom
Caswell over there mentioned to me
yesterday that Damian wrote called fries
and you can install it by using con
install Damian's um channel and then
rise and then you'll get a nice little
button up at your in your notebook and
you can click it and then depending on
if you have slides or sub slides it'll
render it will render them for you that
way alright still doing good all right
so now we'll switch to the our side of
things so how do you get it you can
google a letter the letter R which
actually works remarkably its but the
first few things you'll get you'll
probably get a link to the our project
you can work your way down there to
install our and the IDE that pretty much
everyone uses in our is our studio I
personally um in here unbiased I like
using the preview version of our studio
just because you get kind of nice cool
bells and whistles on before it's
officially released which usually takes
like a few months so you get to see some
pretty cool stuff if you're on Conda you
can actually install our through Conda
installed see r and r SN so our
essentials and then what that also gives
you um I think it's aaron who works on
like sin pi he wrote the art essentials
a Conda installer he also wrapped in
all's the are colonel for the notebook
so if you use our essential you up you
can actually instead of using Python in
your notebooks you have the option to
use our in your notebooks as well so
importing data there's nothing to load
you're using our it's a domain-specific
language just for analytics so you
really don't need to load anything to
load data and so there's a function
called read CSV and are so in our
periods really don't mean anything or
they do but they don't mean it's not
what you think it's really just part of
the variable name really you don't
really need to use a period to say hey
this is like a sub metha method of a
class so periods are allowed in variable
names in our another gotcha in our
especially if you know your you see this
read CSV file and then you use it this
read CSV function you use it it's great
a lot of our programmers know that
there's a parameter called strings as
factors and you always set it to false
what happens is if you just use the
default read CSV functions if you have
any columns that are strings it gets
converted into a factor in Python and
pandas that's essentially what they've
they have a fairly new data type called
a category or categorical variable and
so that's what a factor is it's a
categorical variable in terms of from
the pandas world and factors under the
hood are actually coded as integers so
they're really 123456 for you know or
one and two for like male or female for
example right so if you start trying to
do like string parsing on a factor
you'll find very quickly that nothing is
doing what you're expecting you can yeah
so just keep in mind under the hood is
that it's really being coded as an
integer so just you know our it stems
from the fact that our has been around
for a while and it came from a program
called s and the reason why I got coded
into an integer is really just the save
memory but our laptops these days have
enough memory that you know storing the
strings it's actually you know just to
clean your data it's just a lot easier
just to work with strings ours also um i
would say kind of like a weird language
because uh there's a man named Hadley
Wickham and he's actually made our
really accessible to newcomers but also
changing everything there is about our
so it really depends on like when you
learned our is how you will write our
code I'm sort of in this world where
like I used some of his packages and
others not and so like eels you'll hear
this day in the art world called the
tidy verse which stems from you know
this concept that Hadley wrote about
about tidy data and so if you want to
use the tidy first way of loading data
there there are three packages
essentially read our to read delimited
files I can make this bigger or not or
not read our will read the limited files
read XL will read excel sheets and Haven
to read stuff like SAS SPSS source data
data and when you use Hadleys packages
since everyone uses strings as factors
as false he just makes that the fall for
you so you don't have to specify that
and Hadley uses underscores so that's
how you can kind of tell when you're in
the Hadley world deadly or tidy verse
world of things is the periods are all
gone and you see under sores are also
unlike Python doesn't have a what is it
called like a namespace associated with
it it really is the order of the
packages that you load that is the that
is the order of functions that when you
call that's what it will um in that or
in that order is what it will see first
so if you have two functions and two
packages that have the same name the
last loaded package is that's the
function it will use if you need to
force call a function you will what you
will do is you take the package that
you're using or that you're looking or
the package that you want to colin's and
then the function and then that's how
you explicitly call a specific function
so I think within like one of Hadleys
packages there is a built-in method
or mean and so whether you want to use
his mean function or base RS main
function this is how you would specify
which one from which and so uh and
pandas we had a fun of a parameter
called shape and are we can use a dim
four dimensions to see what the
dimensions of our data are and we get
the same results back first number
represents rose second result second
number represents columns just like
describe an info we can take the summary
of our data and I'll give us a bunch of
summary statistics on our data frame in
our if you want a subset use a dollar
sign if you want to subset a single
column you can also use the square
bracket notation so this looks like very
similar to python if you want the subset
multiple ones um it's the same thing as
Python you have to put in a container to
sub to specify multiple columns but the
way our specifies that container is the
letter C the function C and then you
list your elements in there so you can
think of see the function in R is like a
list in Python yes so this is there is a
comma at the start and so the square
bracket notation is the things that a
left up the comma is how you subset rose
things to the right of the column is how
you subset columns so it's fairly
similar syntax in that regard and the
other difference in our is our is one
index so the first column now starts
with the number one not zero if you're
like me or pretty much every programmer
always is off by one but depending for
me depending on what our in a day I'm in
our Python so like I really make this
mistake like all the time then I'm that
i have a check for if you want to do
something like boolean subsetting it's
very similar to the Python syntax you
can say hey I want all of the cases from
Sierra Leone give me those that are
greater than 5,000 and then I only want
the first two columns and will return
that value to our Python will sort of
drop the missing Valley
used by default are won't so that's why
you see a bunch of missing values here
oh say alright so in Python I showed you
you can look at type the function type
to see what you have in our that instead
of type it's called class so you can
date the class of something if you're
ever confused of what type of object
that you're getting especially when
you're going when you're working with
the Thai diverse set of functions I'm
hadley also essentially redefined what a
data frame is they're called Tibbles and
so depending on what package you're
using it might only accept data frame
objects and not Tibbles so if that's if
it's something that like makes a lot of
sense and you're confused what it is why
it's not working you know take the class
of it just to see that you're actually
passing the correct data type just like
in Python if you're really getting one
column of information in Python you get
a series back here you get essentially a
set of integers so everything is a
vector in R so this is an integer vector
in R if you're subsetting multiple
columns by default you'll get back like
data frame object all right so creating
new things there is a package in are
called Mac Ritter and what my gritter
that gives you is this not to carpal
tunnel inducing of a syntax but what it
it's the pipe operator and the way the
pipe operator works is it takes the
thing to the left and that thing to the
left gets passed in as the first
parameter to the thing on the right so
you can pipe your are you can pipe your
commands or your functions one into the
other and it plays really well into this
whole tidy verse of things or if you're
like me it saves me like a few
keystrokes to go to the beginning of the
line type head and then go to the
underline and then close the parentheses
so you can use that as well if you load
up some any of like Headley's package as
mag Ritter gets loaded automatically so
you're pretty much you don't have to
explode
we load this mag greater packages for a
pipe but if you want to create new
columns it's very similar to the way you
do it in Python you can find a way to
subset the column that you want and you
can if it's a simple operation you can
add the two columns together and i'll
just do exactly what you expect so there
is a the tidy verse way of creating new
columns so if you load up a package
called deep liar what you can do is you
can take your original data frame
there's a function called mutate and
then you can specify the calculation
that you want for creating a new column
that way you can create multiple columns
um all in one go what's also cool about
mutate is you can and in the same
function call use this newly created
column for another calculation if you
want to as well missing values are built
into our they're just capital n capital
a and the way you check it again missing
values are never equal to anything so
it's is na for na or is not null for
null values for combining data so we can
load up our data just like before if you
want to concatenate things row wise it's
our bind for the r4 row and then if you
want to concatenate column wise it's c4
column so see bind four columns if you
want to do merges there's a base our
function called merge and just like in
pandas you have a left side and the
right side in this case there's an X and
a Y and you can specify different ways
you want to merge that way the tidy
verse way there is a function called
full join or left join right join or
inner join and you can specify how you
want to join data that way as well one
of the benefits I guess this I should be
a little more explicit what's cool about
deep liar is if you wrote this code out
just like this this is for a regular
data frame that you load it into our if
you end up working let's say this data
gets so big that you need to dump it
into a database the rest of your code
owed from whatever the first initial
data frame you can pass it the database
connection and the rest of your code
doesn't need to change so it kind of
will scale that way for you it's smarter
to know that if you give it a database
connection it knows to work with the
database and under the hood will write
the sequel string for you and then query
the database that way vector it
operations just like before there is a
apply function just like in pandas you
give it the first data frame that you
want to apply on margin is similar to
axes so whether you want to work row
wise or column wise you specify one or
two and then the function that you want
to use so right here I wrote the
function just like i did in Python like
the lambda expression where I wrote the
function right there if you want you can
also specify the function as its own
function and then call the function
directly right there all right so
grouped operations I use the plier
pretty much all the time Jared Lander
and there's a link to a YouTube video
has performance metrics for besar and
various other packages on how you can do
aggregate statistics this is really a
table from his talk on what that looks
like and essentially a deep liar RC
writing your own our c++ code to do a
join our group that aggregation zor
there's another package called data
table or actually the quickest way of
doing these and the way you specify
group's operations is very similar to
Python it there is a function called
group by and then from within group by
you can calculate whatever you want
whatever group statistic that you need
and so in here I'm just calculating the
mean for both but again you can
calculate min or max if needed if you
want to fit a model there's really
nothing special there's a function for
called LM for linear model glm for a
generalized linear model there's
something called a formulas intact so
you can specify the why and then the
all and you add more calm more variables
by added by having a plus sign so if i
wanted population OB + pop and i can
just add more co fat covariance and my
model if you want to look at my model
you take the summary of your model
object and you'll get everything that
you need david robinson he works in he
work he's a data scientist at stack
overflow he gave a our talk about a
package called broom and what broom does
is it sort of tidies or cleans up all
your model objects so what you can do is
called the tidy function from broom give
it your model and just give you a data
frame of all of your um your model
parameters if you need to so it's a
pretty good way of pretty quick way of
you know getting all the values that you
need so here's some more things on tidy
verse of i guess i'll just show you and
to make these slides this was done in
our studio but it's really using a
package called knitter and our mark down
and by default if you use the GUI ill
dumped you some kind of Gamal header at
the top and you'll generate slides like
this as well all right I mean how much
more time do I have like a minute really
okay all right is there seriously a
minute okay I can do this all right so I
showed you how to work on r and python
has anyone heard of a package called
feather alright so there is a package
called feather sort of like what Jake
van der plas discussed um Hadley Wickham
and so one of the prominent figures in
our and West McKinley one of the
prominent figures in Python they're
working together to make it so you can
easily share data from arm python and
it's a package called feather and in
this repository there's an example of
you know using feather to save out data
from our and then using feather from
Python to read it back in and it's a lot
the whole point is this is a lot faster
than reading out or writing out CSV
files between your files the only thing
is it's really not made for primetime
yet so don't use it like
you're trying like in a bank but if
you're like if you need to quickly send
somebody a file this is something that
to look at out for in the future yeah um
you can really name it like whatever
extension but I just called it dot
feather yeah and then if you want
there's a package called rpy to that I
really couldn't get working but it lets
you call are from within Python so I'll
sort of update this repository as I
figure things out but yes that is my
talk on someone else's computer oh how
do you install our packages in our there
is a function called install dot
packages you give it and then a set of
round brackets and single quotes the
name of the package that you want Conda
yeah so um if you look at the last slide
on my Python deck I showed you like
Conda installed um dash see Damien thing
I see just yeah you can do kinda install
like network X and O for the most part
you'll find it so I think about to go
back the way you had the error a jeweled
psychic oh I know what the problem is
but yeah I just want to see I'm just
curious to see if this will work oh aii
wasn't rendering in off a notebook or
anything I think this was a no I pushed
yeah I push changes that I shouldn't
have pushed it yeah I it was quite a
genki way to get this working because of
our py 2 I had to like change my path
for like a different slide deck yeah
yeah yeah it's it's because i don't have
it installed because i took so sorry is
this actually a live session no no it's
not yeah it's a static session yeah
which I will fix but yeah ok sorry yeah
no problem all right
you